Notre correspondant
Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair.
- Dans les rues de Paris, c'est
un rythme maintenant établi :
30 km/heure, voilà la nouvelle
limite imposée sur presque
tous les axes routiers.
- Paris est une ville
extrêmement petite, très, très
dense, avec beaucoup de conflits
d'usages entre, par exemple,
les automobilistes,
les deux-roues motorisés,
les vélos et puis les piétons.
- Selon lui, la réduction de
vitesse a fait ses preuves dans
d'autres villes européennes.
DAVID BELLIARD,
maire adjoint, Paris
- À Bruxelles, c'est -25 %
d'accidents graves depuis que
la vitesse maximale est passée
de 50 km/heure à 30 km/heure.
Là où cette mesure a été mise
en place, eh bien, on en voit
des effets sur la sécurité
des individus.
- La mesure vise aussi
à s'attaquer à la pollution
sonore. Mais pour ce qui est de
la lutte contre les changements
climatiques, les effets directs
sont beaucoup moins clairs.
Une étude récente d'une agence
publique avance même que la
voiture serait moins polluante
à des vitesses supérieures
à 30 km/heure.
Mais à terme, cette mesure
pourrait contribuer à réduire
le nombre de véhicules
sur les routes.
TONY RENUCCI, Assoc. nationale
amélioration de qualité de l'air
- À 30 km/heure, on va aussi
revoir l'organisation
de la voirie pour qu'elle soit
mieux partagée entre
les automobilistes,
les cyclistes , les piétons.
Et donc ces quelques centimètres
qu'on enlèvera aux voitures,
on pourra les réaffecter
à d'autres usages, mais
les effets sur la qualité
de l'air, on ne pourra les voir
qu'avec le recul et
avec le temps.
- Cette mesure s'inscrit dans
une vision plus large que défend
l'administration parisienne.
Dès l'année prochaine, la ville
pourrait grandement limiter
la circulation automobile dans
les arrondissements centraux
de Paris; seuls certains
véhicules seraient autorisés
à y accéder.
Le but est d'empêcher
les automobilistes de transiter
par ces quartiers.
D'ailleurs, au coeur de Paris,
un projet pilote existe déjà
sur l'iconique rue de Rivoli.
Parmi ceux qui peuvent
y circuler : les transports
en commun, les taxis,
les véhicules de livraison et
les voitures des commerçants
et résidents.
AURÉLIEN VÉRON, conseiller Paris
p.-p. opposition en urbanisme
- Ce sont des très grands axes,
des axes majeurs qui bloquent
complètement la circulation,
qui créent une thrombose.
Ça a des répercussions
sur l'activité économique, ça a
des répercussions sur l'activité
commerçante. Les commerces
de niche, qui ont une clientèle,
on va dire variée,
de banlieusards qui viennent
de loin pour un commerce
spécifique, ne viennent plus.
- Selon ce conseiller
d'opposition, d'autres méthodes
comme le péage seraient
plus efficaces pour contrôler
la circulation. Il déplore
l'approche de l'administration.
- Il y a la méthode de
l'emmerdement, c'est-à-dire
on crée du bouchon, on crée
des noeuds de circulation
qui sont infranchissables.
- Mais pour les dirigeants
de la ville, pas question
de changer de direction.
- Pour transformer la ville,
pour l'adapter au dérèglement
climatique, eh bien oui,
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui,
eh bien, de diminuer la place
de la voiture.
- Cette stratégie passe
entre autres par la limite
à 30 km/heure, une mesure qui,
selon un récent sondage,
obtient l'appui d'une majorité
des résidents de la ville.
De toute façon, la nouvelle
règle ne changera pratiquement
rien au quotidien de nombreux
automobilistes parisiens.
- On roule pas à plus de
30 km/h, c'est tout le temps
bouché! Donc ça sert à rien,
on n'est jamais à 30, on est
toujours à 12-15 km/heure.
- Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Pa